(audience cheers)
- We've hit the moment
when I get to share with you
something totally amazing
that you may have missed
on your social feeds.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
Looking for work as a
mom isn't always easy.
Sometimes there's no
one to watch the kiddos
when you're brought in for an interview.
One mama came up with a creative
way to tackle that dilemma.
She brought her son Milo
along but it's how she did it,
that's attracted so much attention. Watch.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
(audience claps)
I mean, I would hire her like on the spot.
That's amazing.
That's right.
Just like his mom Maggie,
Milo was dressed in proper work attire.
He had his resume, all set and
he walked in with confidence.
We have Maggie and Milo
on the line right now.
What's up?
(audience cheers)
- Hi.
(audience claps)
- Ah!
Oh man, a little one in a little suit
is never not adorable.
So were you hesitant
to take Milo with you?
- You know what Kelly
I have been a national sales
trainer with a company.
It was about 13 years when
I was with the company,
I was laid off.
Sorry, you know how this is.
- Yes, absolutely let him run.
- I was laid off during my pregnancy leave
and so when I finally had
an opportunity to interview
with the company and they invited me back
for a second interview, I was excited,
but I had to let them know
that I didn't have childcare.
And they replied by letting me know
that they were family friendly.
And so I was excited and gladly accepted.
And then let them know that I would have
my little interview ready also.
So I dressed him up in a little suit
and made him a little resume
and just to have fun with it.
- Oh my god. It's amazing.
So how did the interview go?
- It was amazing.
So when I went in, it was
completely not traditional.
As you might imagine,
he ate the owners pickle
and it was a great experience.
(laughs)
I ultimately declined the position.
It just wasn't the right fit
for me, now I'm consulting,
but it led to a great
conversation worldwide
about the childcare crisis.
And it gave me a platform
to talk about how
this is impacting parents like me.
And so many people responded to my Tiktok
and it was like we created
this mini community.
It was amazing.
Even Senator Elizabeth
Warren shared my Tiktok
and I'm excited to share
with you that next year
I will get to go to Washington DC.
And I actually get to talk to
a group of about 300 people
sharing my experience to advocate
for the childcare crisis in the US.
(audience cheers)
- That's amazing.
Wow,
(audience claps)
that's an amazing opportunity
that you're honestly
gonna help out a lot of parents out there
that have a hard time finding childcare.
It's hard to keep a job
and keep that balance
alive with your family.
Well, thank you so much, Maggie.
And thank you Milo!
(audience cheers)
We're liking your post right now.
(audience claps)
Well, that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna give you a 1000 dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh, thank you Kelly.
Thank you.
[Kelly] No, absolutely.
And good luck going to DC that's awesome.